au québec et
je sais pas pour vous mais souvent quand
on parle de racisme on essaie de dire
que ça existe pas on est vraiment dans
le déni total plus complet les
communautés racisées de montréal se
mobilisent pour combattre une racisme
systémique et discute de son ampleur au
sein de la société québécoise
9h05 l'usiné des mondial qu'on voit en
ce moment c'est que moi qui venais fin
des années 80 je veux pas regarder la
télévision sans voir l'image négative de
la film on présente ou d'alexis ailleurs
l'on présentait en présentant fait jouer
pays j'étais paris noir du pays vont pas
bien éviter que dans lequel le temps on
en redemande
c'est la seule zone d'accès la maison
monsieur été c'est comme si tout ce qui
c'est mieux ne vient pas des noirs est
quand même savoir c'est luc sont
produits qui viennent de noir on met le
lendemain dessus en sorte que beaucoup
de contributions sont dépassées la sorte
la même chose qu'au mieux quand c'est
que tu nous as et citic securities et
culture savante 1 où ces ghettos skin
llc votera dans une telle situation en
fonction avec un ssd va sans toi il est
aujourd'hui possible de chiffrer la
discrimination systémique au québec pour
mieux saisir sa structure et ses
conséquences sur la population
ici un noir avaient plus de chances de
se faire interpeller par la police qu
aux etats unis les chances de ce parti
sont cinq fois plus grand ici pour un
noir donc ici aussi quand on arrête les
jeunes justement par rapport à des
infractions de la sorte il faut
comprendre que les procureurs de la
couronne qui vont poser des accusations
ici à travers tout le québec
c'est tous des québécois d'origine
canadienne-française dans ce qui veut
dire qu'il ya pas noire comme les
procureurs de la couronne c'est que dans
les postes de pouvoir donc dans la haute
hiérarchie c'est dans la fonction
publique y recevant sec pour 1 9 % de
ces gens là qui sont issus des minorités
racisées à montréal et qu'on parle du
secteur privé où l'on parle de seulement
2 points 6 % et le père d'adam c'est que
les femmes elles les femmes blanches ils
sont 15% dans ces postes-là mais les
femmes racisées c'est seulement 0,4 pour
cent donc elles sont pratiquement
inexistants dans ces postes de pouvoir
les personnes noires qui ont un diplôme
universitaire de deuxième cycle une
personne noire va en sortant directement
de l'université va faire 28 dollars
en moyenne une personne blanche donc ça
c'est un appauvrissement économique
juste basée sur la race - florent comme
hydro québec elle à 312 employés qui
sont issus des minorités racisées sur
20000 donc sauvé mais ça veut dire 56%
et quand on parle du québec les
minorités racisées c'est 11%
maintenant quand on arrive à montréal
les minorités racisées c'est 30%
et quand on regarde les élus en poste il
y en a quatre sur 103 on a dépassé
l'ordre du folklorique de nous dire
quelques paroles en créole venir faire
quelques steppettes dans un bar et pour
dire comme ça j'aime les haïtiens on
veut du tangible
ce que je veux dire c'est pas normal que
montréal en os cas une grosse population
haïtienne que ce soit l'un des
arrondissements le plus pauvre et qu'il
n'y a pas d'investissement clair pour
changer la chose un effort d coûte
d'éducation et d'intérêt pour l'histoire
est nécessaire pour comprendre la
réalité quotidienne de tous les
québécois et québécoises précisé c'est
pas lui même est pas raciste est un
construit le racisme est donc comme
contenu que cette construit humain on
peut le déconstruire également